[موسيقى]
هذا جنيه وهذا نصف جنيه وهذا ربع جنيه
كانت هذه العملات تمثل مصروف المدرسه منذ
بضع سنوات كنت اذهب الى المدرسه فرحا
لشراء الفطور به فالجنيه كان كافيا لشراء
قطعتيك وعلبه عصير تفاح المفضله لديك
[موسيقى]
لم تمر الكثير من الاعوام لارى اليوم
مصروف المدرسي يباع في البازارات كعمله
تذكاريه قديمه باضعف ثمنه ومازلت في
العشرينات من عمري
النصف جنيه والربع جنيه والخمسه قروش
والعشره قروش التي كانت المصروفه المدرسيه
اليوم للاطفال من جيل الثمانينات
والتسعينات تباع حاليا في حافظه
البلاستيكيه بمبالغ تتراوحو ما بين 65 و
70 جنيها
[موسيقى]
ولكن ليس هذا وحده العجيب فنحن نرى كل
طفولتنا اليوم يراها اشقاءنا الصغار تراثا
في افلام كرتون سابق ولاحق والمغامرون
الخمسه ولعبه الاتاري
وشرائط الكاسيت اصبحت ايضا قديمه وتذكاريه
كما ربع جنيه وانت ماذا اصبح تذكاريا من
طفولتك